sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
Sie recht herzlich zur heutigen
Pressekonferenz hier in großmittel
begrüßen zu meiner Linken
Verteidigungsministerin Frau Claudia
Danner der generalstoffchef Rudolf
stridinger und der Kommandant des
panzerbatterie und 14 Herr Oberst Jörg
Leuthold sehr geehrte Frau
Verteidigungsminister ich würde sie um
ihre Worte ersuchen ja vielen Dank sehr
geehrter Herr generalstoff
Kommandanten Soldatinnen Soldaten sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren von der Presse
wir alle wissen es Jahrzehnte lang wurde
unser österreichisches Bundesheer
vernachlässigt insbesondere budget-mäßig
vernachlässigt und jetzt gilt es diese
Versäumnisse aufzuholen das gelingt
deshalb weil uns im Vorjahr das höchste
landesverteidigungsbudget in der
Geschichte des österreichischen
Bundesheeres im Parlament beschlossen
worden ist darüber hinaus auch ein
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
dass unser Planbarkeit gibt dass uns
eine Grundlage schafft dass wir unsere
Fähigkeiten noch klar entwickeln können
das heißt mein Ressort hat in den
kommenden vier Jahren 16 Milliarden Euro
als Verteidigungsbudget zur Verfügung
damit können wir diese vielen
Investitionen tätigen die jahrelang oder
sagen wir besser Jahrzehnte lang auf der
Strecke geblieben sind unsere Mission
die lautet vorwärts wir haben sie am
Nationalfeiertag ausgerufen wir wollen
und wir müssen unser Bundesheer moderner
und einsatzfähiger gestalten wir haben
dazu einen Zehnjährigen Aufbauplan
erstellt sie kennen die
investitionsschwerpunkte die zum einen
die Bereich der Mobilität der
Einsatzkräfte umfasst zum anderen den
Schutz der Soldatinnen und Soldaten wo
es um die Beschaffung von modernen ausrü
schaffen und Gerät geht und die Autarkie
zur Stärkung der
Verteidigungsbereitschaft ja zum Punkt
tippen der Verbesserung der Mobilität
der Einsatzkräfte da legen wir das
Schwergewicht im Bereich der geschützten
Mobilität und in der Ergänzung der
geschützten Fahrzeugflotte weiter sind
dringend benötigte Transporter Fahrzeuge
wie zum Beispiel eben die Radpanzer
Pandur hier noch einmal auch angemerkt
aus österreichischer Produktion weiters
auf schnelle hochbewegliche Fahrzeuge
für Spezialeinsatzkräfte und in von
Dresden sowie geschützte Pionier und
sanitätsfahrzeuge heute stehe ich aber
da um insbesondere mitteilen zu können
dass wir ein sehr großes
Investitionspaket für die robuste
militärische Komponente einsetzen werden
wir haben damit bereits vor dem
Angriffskrieg Putins auf die Ukraine
begonnen der eine oder andere von ihnen
kann sich noch erinnern an den zwölften
Februar 2021
Pressekonferenz in der
rossauer-kaserne zu diesem Zeitpunkt
haben wir mit dem Planungen begonnen
aber selbstverständlich hat der Krieg im
und um Europa alles verändert und
insbesondere deutlich gemacht dass eine
gut aufgestellte Landesverteidigung
gerade für einen neutralen Staat von
existenzieller Bedeutung ist
wir müssen erleben dass neben Hybriden
Bedrohungen die konventionelle
Kriegsführung an Bedeutung gewonnen hat
wir müssen uns daher auf dem
militärischen Schutz der
österreichischen Souveränität gegen
konventionell agierende Kräfte nicht nur
besinnen sondern insbesondere
rückbesinnen
nach intensiver und gründlicher
Beurteilung durch meinen Generalstab
habe ich mich als ersten Schritt für den
weiteren Betrieb der beiden Flotten also
das Kampfpanzers Leopard A2 A4 und
andererseits den Schützenpanzer olan bis
weit ins nächste Jahrzehnt entschieden
denn hier auch ganz offen angesprochen
große Beschaffungsvorhaben die dauern
Jahre mit einem ersten
Investitionsvolumen von 560 Millionen
Euro werden wir bis zum Jahr 2029
insgesamt 170 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
modernisiert haben das betrifft 58
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 A4 und 112
Schützenpanzer olan das ist damit das
größte Investitionspaket nach der
Beschaffung der 36 Hubschrauber des Typs
Leonardo sie das war eine
Investitionssumme von 873 Millionen Euro
es ist insbesondere ein nächster großer
Schritt zu einem modernen her sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich brauche zum
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 eigentlich nicht
viel zu sagen denn fast täglich hören
wir in der Medienberichterstattung zum
ukrainekrieg über diesen Fahrzeugtyp und
auch wir in Österreich sind überzeugt
von der Notwendigkeit dieses Panzers und
daher ist eine Verlängerung der Nutzung
in Österreich unumgänglich
betrifft so haben wir hier ein rein
österreichisches Produkt das gemeinsam
mit dem Kampfpanzer Leopard Träger des
Gefechts der mechanisierten Brigade ist
bereits im Dezember konnten wir die
Verträge für die Nutzungsdauer
Verlängerungen unter Dach und Fach
bringen zum einen und die Vertreter der
Unternehmen sind ja auch heute hier
anwesend zum einen wurde ein Vertrag mit
der Firma grossmaffei Wegmann GmbH aus
München fixiert und zum anderen mit der
Firma general dynamic
europeansystems Steyr GmbH aus Wien
unterschrieben
so wird die Mission vorwärts nicht nur
ein Slogan sein sondern wir haben
konkrete Taten
gesetzt und das werden wir auch in
Zukunft tun müssen während wir sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren hier unser
Pressegespräch haben werden draußen
unsere Techniker der Wehrtechnik des
heereslogistikzentrums Klagenfurt und
der beiden Verbände
panzergrenadierbatterien 13 und
Panzergrenadierbataillon 35 bereits die
ersten Schützenpanzer Ulan an die Firma
General Dynamics vorbereiten es ist mir
ein Bedürfnis mich zu bedanken mich zu
bedanken bei allen Beteiligten in
unserem Haus insbesondere bei meinem
rüstungsdirekt und seinem Team im und
aber auch beim bei den Vertretern der
Industrie für das große Engagement in
dieser Angelegenheit gerade im Krieg um
Europa ist es wichtig dass wir eine
starke industrielle Basis haben haben in
Europa und auch in Österreich und das
wird diese auch weiter stärken daher
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren diese
Investition ist nicht nur eine dringend
notwendige Verstärkung der
mechanisierten Truppe um die
Verteidigungsbereitschaft Österreichs zu
erhalten sondern sie ist auch eines sie
ist ein starkes Signal an Europa im
Rahmen der gemeinsamen sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik dankeschön
sehr geehrte general ich würde sie um
ihre Worte aussuchen sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesminister sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren nach diesen Worten unserer
Bundesministerin und vor den Worten des
Bataillonskommandanten des
Panzerbataillons gestatten Sie mir dass
ich nicht ganz unmittelbar auf den
heutigen anders eingehe sondern sie ein
bisschen in andere Aspekte die aber
deutlich dazu gehören entführe
zunächst in eine militärstrategische
militärhistorische Reise ein bisschen in
die Vergangenheit und zu verstehen warum
das Bundesheer dort steht wo wir jetzt
sind
wir hatten während des Kalten Krieges 3
mechanisierte brigadener so
panzergrenadierbrigaden heutzutage nur
noch eine
nach Ende des Kalten Krieges fand in
Europa und in Österreich eine Abrüstung
statt die Konsequenz
Truppenstärken reduziert hat aber auch
mechanisiertes schweres Gerät massiv
reduziert wurde
trotzdem wurde in den 90er Jahren ein
sogenanntes milchpaket geschnürt und die
Fahrzeuge die wir heute zur Verfügung
haben wurden damals geschafft der
Leopard 2 und der Ulan
in den 2000er Jahren fand unter Helmut
Zilk die bundesheerreformkommission
statt und in der weiten Folge das
Projekt Bundesheer 2010 mit der
Zielsetzung das österreichische
Bundesheer auf den Auslandseinsatz zu
konzentrieren in seinen Bemühungen
Anstrengungen in der Organisation in der
Ausrüstung
konsequenter Weise fand die redund
weitere Reduzierung von mechanisierter
Truppe also Panzer und Panzergrenadiere
statt wie auch der Fliegerabwehr wo wir
heuer zu Tage ein deutliches Manko haben
wir haben uns oft sogenannte
rekonstruktionskerne reduziert weil wir
gesagt haben wir brauchen das
offensichtlich in Zukunft nicht mehr
zumindest in der Größenordnung
danach kam die Finanzkrise die
mobilitätskrise die migrationskrise
lauterentwicklungen die weiterhin zum
Abbau des österreichischen Bundesheeres
geführt haben und vor allem zu einem
Zustand der Fahrzeuge um die es heute
geht wo die Einsatzbereitschaft deutlich
und konsequent abgenommen hat
und bereits mit 2020 wie unsere
bundesministerinnen ins Amt gekommen hat
haben wir darüber nachgedacht ob dieser
Weg der richtige ist und festgestellt
aufgrund der krisenentwicklung in Europa
auch im Osten bereits
etc
kam es zu einer sogenannten rückbeziehen
und wir haben dann 2021 ein neues
streitkräfteprofil festgelegt wo nicht
mehr der Auslandseinsatz sondern der
Einsatz des österreichischen
Bundesheeres zum Zwecke der
militärischen Landesverteidigung Inland
in den Vordergrund gerückt wurde
und jetzt stand natürlich die Frage was
macht man mit diesen
Panzern Schützenpanzern die quasi ins
Alter gekommen sind was tut man mit
ihnen
und nicht zum Glück aber doch auslösend
war dann im Jahr 2022 die Situation die
wir alle kennen in der Ukraine die dazu
geführt hat dass dem österreichischen
Bundesheer die ausreichenden Mittel zur
Verfügung gestellt werden
innerhalb der nächsten zehn Jahre so
dass wir in der Lage sind alle Panzer
Schützenpanzer des österreichischen
Bundesheeres wieder auf einen modernen
und zukunftsträchtigen Stand zu bringen
der zweite Punkt den ich ansprechen
möchte ist unsere personalage
wir alle wissen und das sieht man
überall dass es so der Arbeitsmarkt
tatsächlich nicht mehr das hergibt was
der Bedarf ist
wir haben auch gleichzeitig hohe
pensionswellen im öffentlichen Dienst
auch bei uns das führt dazu dass wir
alle um dieselbe Ressource
Arbeitskräfte kämpfen und es ist eines
unserer wichtigsten Ziele die
Personallage des Bundesheeres in diese
Richtung zu entwickeln dass wir in der
Lage sind mit dem dann modernen Gerät
des Bundesheeres mit der modernen
Ausrüstung die zur Verfügung gestellt
werden kann auch ein zukunftsträchtiges
einsatzbereites Bundesheer zu machen und
zwar nicht nur was den präsenzstand
betrifft also die Soldaten in den
Berufssoldaten sondern vor allem auch
was die Milz betrifft das heißt das
österreichische Bundesheer ist ein
attraktiver Arbeitgeber
für
berufssoldatinnen Berufssoldaten und für
Soldatinnen und Soldaten in der Miliz
wir haben in Zukunft ein modernes Gerät
wir werden auch eine sehr moderne
personenbezogene Ausstattung für die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten haben
wir werden wieder mehr üben wer bei uns
zum Bundesheer kommt wird seine
militärischen Aufgabenstellung die er
nämlich erwartet zugeführt werden
und wir werden ein Schwergewicht bei der
Rekrutierung von Soldatinnen entwickeln
in den nächsten Monaten ein ganz ein
wichtiger Punkt
und wir haben eine Vielzahl von Impulsen
und Initiativen die wir setzen wollen
und setzen müssen damit Sie unsere
Personallage in die richtige Richtung
entwickelt und abschließend möchte ich
feststellen wer geistig und körperlich
fit ist der kann auch österreichischer
Soldatinnen und österreichischer Soldat
werden danke schön
abschließende suche ich den Kommandanten
des Panzerbataillon 14 Herrn Oberst Jörg
Leuthold und seine Worte sehr geehrte
Frau Bundesminister sehr geehrte general
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
stellvertretend für die
bataillierungskommandanten der vierten
Panzergrenadierbrigade aber auch für die
alle batterienskammer Landes
österreichischen Bundesheeres möchte ich
kurz beleuchten was der Bundeswehr
Aufbauplan 2032 für einen kleinen
Verband bedeutet
auf das Panzerplatten 14 als das schwere
mechanisierte Rückgrat der landeskräfte
kommen mit der nutzungsverlängerung
großer Veränderungen zu mit der
nutzungsverlängerung wird das
panzerbaron 14 in allen drei Bereichen
des auffahrplans des Bundesheeres also
bei Mobilität Schutz und Wirkung
Autarkie und Nachhaltigkeit seinen
Beitrag leisten durch die volle
Digitalisierung der Bedienelemente und
der Datenübertragung des Kampfpanzers
einhergehend mit der erheblichen
Verbesserung der nachtkampffähigkeit
wird eine aufschulung aller
ausgebildeten Berufs-
dafür erhält das Panzer 2014 neben dem
Kampfpanzer auch neue simulationsmittel
von der Ebene Besatzungsmitglied
Panzerfahrer Richtschütze Ladeschütze
und Kommandant bis zum Panzerzug die
gesamte Ausrüstung des Zubehör das
Kampfpanzers werden überarbeitet und
angepasst
im Zuge der Einführung des tarnenzuges
wird auch die flammenhemme die
Bekleidung erneuert und im zivilen
Standard angepasst
neben dem Kampfpanzer als Träger des
Gefechts werden auch die
unterstützungsfahrzeuge nachgezogen hier
wird es auf der Plattform Leopard 2 zu
einer vereinheitlich kommt eine kommen
die Implementierung von Luft und Land
Drohnen zur Aufklärung Feuerleitung
innerhalb der panzerkomponie erhöhen die
Fähigkeit noch gezielter Wirkung ins
Ziel zu bringen
das gesamte beschriebene Paket wird
natürlich auch in allen Vorschriften
technischen Anweisungen sowie im
Organisationsplan nachgezogen
voll digitale Kampffahrzeuge benötigen
auch zeitgemäße Infrastruktur die
entsprechenden Planungen inklusive
photovoltaikanlagen sind die der
hessenkaserne in Wels bereits voll
angelaufen neben diesen
zukunftsweisenden Aufgaben wird
natürlich auch die laufende Ausbildung
von der Basisausbildung von der Rekruten
bis zur volltruppenübung am Kampfbahn in
Deutschland und Österreich durchgeführt
zu widerständige Beitrag zum
Assistenzeinsatz abgedeckt
all dies erfordert motivierte Rekruten
Miliz und Berufssoldaten Frauen und
Männer die bereits in ihren Dienst für
Österreich beim Passwort 2014 zu leisten
selbst redend wird das Passwort 2014
auch ständig neues Personal und bietet
jeder und jedem egal mit welchem
Hintergrund und mit welcher
Vorausbildung die Möglichkeit Teil
dieses wohl einmaligen Projekts im
panzerhort zu werden zum Schluss möchte
ich natürlich der ressortführung im
Besonderen ihnen sehr gefragt sehr
geehrte Frau Bundesminister und Ihnen
sehr geehrter general aber auch allen
Welser Hessen die diesen Weg gehen
aufrichtig für den Einsatz danken danke
schön
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
sie nun um etwaige Fragen ersuchen
wann gehen denn die ersten Panzer noch
Deutschland um umgebaut zu werden und
wie lange dauert das Programm so
wie ich in meinen Eingangsworten schon
gesagt habe beginnt es ab sofort in
diesen Minuten von der Dauer her gibt es
einen genauen Plan der eben abschließt
mit dem Jahr 2032 wichtig ist auch noch
zu betonen dass die investsumme die ich
genannt habe mit diesen
560 Millionen Euro ein erster Schritt
ist der gesamte Aufbauplan beinhaltet
weitere Schritte dazu für die konkreten
Abläufe wann sozusagen das Gerät dann
wieder zuläuft würde ich bitten
die ersten der erste Leopard wird im
September diesen Jahres den Weg nach
München antreten die durchlaufdauer pro
Fahrzeug beträgt 30 Monate so dass wir
2026 die ersten neuen Fahrzeuge in
Österreich haben und dann weiter
aufbauen und im Jahr 2028 das Projekt
Panzerbataillon 2032 auf guten Weg sein
sollte
gibt es weitere Fragen
danke
die die Bedienelemente werden
digitalisiert können Sie das ein zwei
Beispiele bringen was es gibt konkret in
der Teil bedeutet also wir haben derzeit
dabei viel am Fahrerstand noch einen
Fahrerstand aus dem Jahr 1980 das heißt
an Manometer Schalter
Kippschalter etc all das wird neu
aufgesetzt das heißt der Fahrer wie zum
Beispiel
Bedienpanel verfügen er wird über ein
sozusagen GPS verfügen oder ein Navi
verfügen er wieder meine Rückfahrkamera
verfügen unter all das wird digital und
auch die Bedienelemente das riecht
schützen und das kann man landen werden
auf diesen Stand nachgezogen das heißt
weg von manuellen scheitern hin zu
bedienen digitaler Art man kann sich ein
gehärtetes Notebook vorstellen dass dort
eingebaut wird und natürlich immer
abgetötet werden kann
gibt es weitere Fragen
nachdem es keine weiteren Fragen gibt
darf ich mich recht herzlich bedanken
und erkläre die Pressekonferenz für
beendet danke sehr